quisiera empezar con una pregunta que yo
considero sencilla por un lado tenemos
una película con un actor que yo
considero muy guapo
interpretando a uno de los asesinos
seriales más famosos de todos los
tiempos por otro lado tenemos al asesino
serial hablando en primera persona de
los crímenes que cometió
cuál prefieres ver
la primera o la segunda se las dejo para
para reflexionar
los crímenes como los que cometen los
asesinos seriales tienen un elemento
infalible para atraer la psique del ser
humano y despertar en nosotros áreas
relacionadas con la lujuria con el miedo
con la actuación sin consecuencias y
aunque usted no lo crea la empatía
creo que es muy fácil decir que desde el
principio de los tiempos el hecho de
matar a otro ser humano en casi todas
las culturas ha sido considerar todo un
hecho condenables
pero primero quiero hablarles un poquito
de qué es un asesino serial ya después
entenderán por qué es importante que
pues hablemos un poco de esto
bueno un asesino serial es aquel que
sigue patrones de conducta en sus
asesinatos sus símbolos sus señales y
sus rituales hay un periodo de tiempo
regular entre sus crímenes y lo más
interesante de esto es que puede ser
cualquier persona los asesinos seriales
casi siempre tienen una personalidad
psicópata o una personalidad antisocial
lo que hace que sea casi imposible saber
quiénes son hay una autora que se llama
james marsden que es es profesora del vi
con college y dice que aquello que hace
que nos atraigan tanto este tipo de
crímenes reales es que podemos intuir en
las mentes más perversas del ser humano
pero se preguntarán vecchia donde vas
con esto porque me está diciendo todo
esto y es por eso que quiero hablar de
locus series de crímenes reales en
plataformas de streaming quiero que
piensen quién no ha visto uno de sus
textos trailers en sus páginas de inicio
y éstas se les pone la piel chinita de
decir ok quiero
este documental quiero ver estado q
seria
grandes empresas de entretenimiento
están apostando por la producción de
series de este tipo porque qué es lo que
hace que nosotros digamos oigan yo
quiero ver esta serie ahora vamos a
hablar un poco sobre eso
yo creo que existe una fórmula infalible
al momento de ver estas dos series el
momento en el que las plataformas de
streaming dicen es hora de poner otra
docus serie en mi plataforma número uno
tenemos que lo hacemos desde la
seguridad y comodidad de nuestra casa lo
que nos permite ver los documentales ver
los crímenes reales como los que cometen
los asesinos seriales desde un entorno
controlado nos permite ser parte de las
historias sin realmente ser parte de las
historias y después existe una frase muy
sencilla muy chiquita que hemos visto en
muchas películas en muchos documentales
y en muchas de sus series que es basado
en hechos reales a mí nada más de ver
eso en la pantalla se me eriza la piel
se enciende un reflejo completamente
natural en el ser humano que dice quiero
entender qué fue lo que llevó a esta
persona a cometer el crimen que cometió
ya sea antes o ya sea que está
cometiendo en estos tiempos
cuando hablamos de docushare esos
documentales de crímenes reales estamos
hablando de historias muy conocidas
historias muy antiguas es realmente casi
imposible hablar de spoilers que es lo
que nos engancha que es lo que hace que
nosotros queramos continuar viendo estas
dos series simplemente queremos
comprender la motivación detrás de esto
queremos comprender que fue lo que llevó
a la persona a cometer esto queremos
desde este entorno controlado que les
comento aprender a no convertirnos en
víctimas aprender a simplemente saber
que el ser humano puede cometer esto y
como me cuido de este ser humano
vamos a hablar de dos q serie de
crímenes reales en plataformas de stream
pica en una plataforma de streaming que
hay alrededor de 162 q series alrededor
de estas 60 son de crímenes reales y 42
son originales vamos a ponerle un poco
en minutos
una de estas plataformas de streaming
más famosas solamente en 2018 publicó 9
series de este tipo 9 series son 3 mil
593 minutos que es igual a 59 horas y 53
minutos si nos ponemos a pensar
realmente la cantidad de horas que
podemos ver en nada más
92 cv series creo que son demasiadas
pero también existen repercusiones
sociales y psicológicas de estas dos
miserias de crímenes reales que muchas
pueden ser muy obvias y hay otras
cuantas que pueden ser sobrevaloradas
comenzamos creo que también el hecho de
ver pues todos estos crímenes reales
puede despertar en nosotros y en ciertas
áreas de ansiedad porque la adrenalina
al ver a una persona cometer un crimen
real hace que nuestro miedo suba y
estemos en estado de alerta lo que
también provoca cierta paranoia nosotros
cuando salimos a la calle cuando estamos
incluso en nuestras casas hemos visto
crímenes en los que los asesinos
seriales o las personas son los
criminales entran al hogar sin
obviamente estar nosotros al pendiente
de esto esto también puede crear que
tengamos muchas pesadillas y que existan
bloqueos a la hora de enfrentarme a una
situación de riesgos
pero lo más importante a lo que quisiera
hablar es de dos ámbitos sobrevalorados
que existen en las dos usuarias de
crímenes reales uno es que distraen del
aburrimiento y ya hablar un poco más de
dos de esto y otro es que desarrollamos
cierto sentido de empatía y usted no
pueden decir ve aquí cómo voy a
desarrollar empatía por esta criminal
que hizo actos tan atroces pues en un
momento les hablaré de eso
no voy a hablar sobre el aburrimiento
heidegger un gran filósofo dijo alguna
vez que las posibilidades que yacen
dormidas aparecen al momento en que uno
comienza a sentir aburrimiento cuando
nosotros tenemos este sentimiento de
vacío pues comenzamos a ver cosas
comenzamos a intentar distraer la mente
y cuando comenzamos a ver estas dos
series de crímenes reales se puede
despertar en nosotros un sentido de
mímesis que es la mímesis es la
representación la participación la
actuación de imitar lo que otra persona
ha imitado si vemos esto desde el punto
de vista de la criminología filosófica
el pasar grandes tiempos de tedio viendo
de ocu serias de crímenes reales nos
puede llevar a querer actuar y admirar
incluso ciertas conductas que la otra
persona ha hecho esto es algo
completamente humano se podrá decir
somos seres miméticos desde que somos
chiquitos estamos aprendiendo a hacer lo
que la otra persona está haciendo
y ahora les quiero comentar un poco
sobre el desarrollo de la empatía sartre
alguna vez dijo que un hombre es lo que
hace y lo que hicieron de elx con lo que
hicieron de él creo que es muy muy
importante saber que la bondad y la
maldad son igual de humanos lo que nos
importa realmente no es el crimen ya
pasó estamos como les dije hablando de
historias antiguas historias conocidas
lo que nos importa es el porqué el saber
que llevó a esta persona a hacer lo que
cometió por ejemplo les quiero comentar
un poco sobre la imagen que vemos
ahorita en pantalla de theodore
kaczynski mejor conocido como el
unabomber alguna vez llegué a ver una
docu sería de él pero les platico un
poco el caso por los que no lo conozcan
cuando él iba en la universidad lo
invitan a participar con engaños a un
experimento en el que querían utilizar
la tecnología para crear se podría decir
ciertas técnicas
pues para dañar un poco la mente humana
y poder controlarlas ahí se las dejo no
esto hizo que obviamente se generara se
generara un gran trauma en el creará una
visión técnica del mundo y cuando
creciera mandará bombas a las grandes
empresas de tecnología les prometo que
cuando vi esta serie lloré la manera en
la que me estaban presentando lo que era
el personaje de lo que fue este horror
kaczynski me hizo sentir tanta empatía
yo dije me etiquete está pasando cómo
sientes empatía por esta persona que
cometió un crimen tan atroz y creo que
la respuesta es muy sencilla para
entender algo tan inhumano buscamos en
nuestra propia humanidad
pero bueno no todo es color de gris
color negro vamos a hablar ahora de lo
invisible a lo invisible de lo inhumano
a lo humano
hay un autor muy bueno que se llama
harold scheckter que escribe sobre
crímenes reales especialista en asesinos
seriales y dice que este tipo de
discusiones son una especie de histeria
cultural es como hablar de cuentos de
hadas para adultos no es eso que nos
atrae y decimos quiero seguirlo viendo
y kirkegaard alguna vez dijo que los
acontecimientos y los otros jugarán un
papel decisivo para saber quién soy y
quién estoy siendo como hombre quiere
decir que quiere decir esto cuando yo
estoy viendo a la otra persona cometer
algo tan atroz me defino y me busco en
mi humanidad para saber quién soy quién
quiero ser y cómo quiero superarme para
llegar a ser la persona que tanto anhelo
cero
vamos a pensar no estamos expuestos a la
violencia 24/7 redes sociales televisión
radio periódico cualquier cosa que se
les ocurra nos están enseñando
literalmente aquí hay violencia y encima
las grandes plataformas de streaming nos
ponen tres mil 593 minutos de contenidos
sobre crímenes reales en solamente nueve
de estas pero qué pasaría si le diéramos
la vuelta a esto
qué pasa si tomamos estas plataformas
para crear conciencia y valor y en ese
momento qué pasaría las platt las series
los docu series de crímenes reales no se
quedan solamente en el morbo en la
curiosidad de limitación en el
aburrimiento sino en un actuar en
realizar una acción
la psicología forense toma el espacio de
las dos ferias de crímenes reales para
generar cambios para generar ayuda y
para generar conciencia pero esto no
nada más es de psicólogos forenses de
criminólogos sociólogos detectives
cualquier cosa que se les pueda ocurrir
muchas plataformas de streaming sus
historias están basadas en víctimas en
familias de víctimas en personas que han
alzado la voz para decir esto fue lo que
sucedió pero quiero hacer de este mundo
un lugar mejor
estos espacios han servido para consolar
validar sentir apoyo sentir vivir
identificación y alzar la voz
muchas personas han alzado la voz han
contado sus historias han salido
inocentes de estos crímenes han se ha
unido a la humanidad para encontrar a
alguien que ha hecho un acto tan atroz y
se ha generado una empatía compartida
entre víctimas y no víctimas para
generar este apoyo entre ambos
por último quisiera concluir con una
frase de un psicólogo social que puedo
decir que uno de mis favoritos philip
sin embargo que dice si quieres cambiar
a una persona tienes que cambiar la
situación muchas gracias